[Music]
Jennifer Lopez and Alex Rodriguez take
their romance to the Caribbean puppy
Yemma et has the pics the superstar
singer and the former baseball pro
aboard a boat in the Bahamas at the
Baker's Bay Golf and ocean club the pair
seem to enjoy some quality time together
relaxing in paradise I really feel
blessed a source close to a rod
explained to et that this is the new
couple's first trip together adding that
JLo flew to Miami with her kids dropped
them off with her ex Mark Anthony and
headed south with a rod to soak up the
Sun the same source said the pair met
through mutual pals explaining quote
they're both single have these huge
careers and their families are their
number one priorities they have a lot in
common and friends thought they could be
really good together that makes me so
happy
then a rod checked out J Lo's Vegas
residency show and according to our
source that's when things started
heating up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are you diggin j-rod as a new couple
tell us your thoughts over on twitter at
ET now
[Music]
you